[Music]
back in the day you know it was um you
had the i would call it the wedding cake
you know it was the cheer do you know
the waterfall the double dip
and that's all being sort of flattened
out these days you never see that
anymore you don't see the double dip
everybody's doing the 1x not
participating
i heard in the valley a while ago that
they've stopped even doing that people
are saying we'll just take ordinary
shares assuming the next guy also takes
ordinary shares you know because if he
gets preferred then i'll have what he's
having but if he's willing to take
ordinary then we'll just all take
ordinary
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders and today
we're in the legal sector
but in tech
meet in valparaiso's team mendelbaum
senior partner in pearl cohen
inval's practices focuses on high-tech
venture capital corporate and commercial
laws imbal advises companies in all
phases of growth from early stages
through m a on all corporate and
commercial aspects
inval pearlsteen mendelbaum thank you
for joining me 20 minute leaders how are
you today
i'm fine thank you very excited to be
here thanks for having me
i'm looking forward to chatting with you
about both your position as a senior
partner at pearlcoin but but also the
way that you're interacting with
startups and especially companies and
you know in venture capital and they
grow in in the growth stages and
emerging stages you know you're you're
working with a lot of companies to
to work on these on these pivotal
moments in their life cycle that push
them forward you're also working with
some amazing accelerators in the
foundation of the 8200 entrepreneurship
unit and you're working a lot and you
know in all these different verticals
and you know oftentimes i get to talk to
founders and investors on the way they
perceive things and here i get to talk
to somebody who's also behind the scenes
a little more but really seeing the the
the bits and pieces so thank you very
much for joining me
it's a pleasure
um
so i think i mean i
i started working um in this industry um
roughly 18 years ago
um i think what drew me to this
particular aspect of law as opposed to
you know being a litigator or you know
any other type of law is is that unlike
other
um legal terrains where it's a sort of
win-lose situation or zero-sum game
um this particular vertical is is not so
so at the end of the day you know
whatever we're negotiating or whatever
we're doing five minutes later once
we're done negotiations and you know and
the ink is drying on the paperwork
people join forces and work together and
you know and take it to the next level
to build a company
so that's what initially drew me you
know to this aspect of the profession i
was also very good at math you know so
and it's and it's um
you have to be somewhat unafraid of
numbers and um and technology you know
at large you know to be able to do this
position well uh in my view and so um
you know initially i was drawn to you
know and it's the startup you know
nation and hype
and
i started working 18 years ago
um with this industry and
what is i find most fulfilling in my job
is you know other than working with
brilliant people on you know bringing
the next level of technology whether
it's the cyber security or digital tech
or
you know
medical
health products
um is that you really get to experience
their growth and you know i usually
start working
with founders at a very very early stage
you know what you would call day one but
actually it's even prior to that so you
know prior to company registration
they're still putting together the team
you still see people you know
coming in and out um
this is also something that is more
frequently seen over the past years i
mean if maybe 10 years ago the founding
team would really stick together for at
least a good couple of months you know i
know if it's millennials or whatever but
you know you see more you know
you see people you know the the team
changes quite a lot even you know up
until the first you know seat or precede
or whatever it's now named um financing
and and then you get to experience you
know working with these people
through you know through their life
cycle you know from the pre-seed seed
and then on to the series a and b and
you know
in the past year i've experienced um
working on two m a transactions quite
you know large and
public um and and this is with clients
that i've been working with for the past
eight years so
it's it's very full yeah it's very
fulfilling and you watch them grow
and there's a lot of tutorial that is
done you know on on the you know on my
end because initially a founder may be
brilliant at what they do but they don't
know you know what dilution means or or
you know right how a find or free
agreement should be constructed or you
know what is the safe
and so
there's really a lot of you know i would
not say mentoring per se but explaining
and and i think that's a big part of my
job is you know to first you know
get the founders and you know the
company sort of up to speed on what is
common what is standard what they should
be looking out for what's important
what's not as important you know what's
a deal break or what's not um and that's
a part of my job that i actually enjoy a
lot um
so
and i think that's something that um
also changes as time goes by so you know
a founder that we're working now on
their b round or their c round you know
they're a different place than they were
you know three years ago and or two
years ago depending how quickly they
evolved you know when we were just
setting up the company and putting
together a founder agreement and you
know every purchase concept was was all
new to them so
that that's
you know that's what i find most
interesting in in the work cycle
incredible now if we're looking at this
position in which you're you're you know
you're working with the founders
especially in the early stages and
you're mentioning that there are a lot
of these you know
complex ideas that you really have to
wrap your mind across and there's so
many different combinations of things
that can happen as we're structuring
deals
what what do you see is most helpful for
founders as they approach these
different negotiations and so you know
even in you know the most common things
like dilution and those types of of
ideas what do founders do in the early
stages to really get acquainted with it
and at what stage should they do it
should it be really early on should it
be as we get closer to the end of the
negotiations
so you know one of the most you know
helpful tools is you know if we're
talking about dilution for example is to
see it perform a cap now you know a
performance cap is an excel sheet and it
rolls out you know the entire
pre-closing post-closing option increase
many times i see founders coming you
know in with you know a you know term
sheet proposal but not even just a term
sheet proposal just you know like the
email with the three lines of you know
we'll put in whatever 5 million at
pre-10 or whatever or 4 3 12 whatever
that might be
um
the whole pre-post closing valuation is
is a concept that people you know it's a
mathematical concept that people need to
understand if somebody's investing for
instance 4 million at a pre-money of 12
he's getting you know one quarter of the
company you know because eventually the
post would be 16 which is the initial 12
plus the four i mean it's it's very
technical and it's very you know
mathy um so i i really try and you know
spell it out for them you know show them
what it would actually mean you know the
the actual cap table
what you know what would it look like um
and that's a working tool that's you
know essential
um but also i try and you know
i think the advantage that that i have
today um is that i've seen these things
sort of come to close i've seen the
cycle go through many times and so i i
can you know many times i can say you
know
you know roughly speaking clearly not on
the tenth of the percentage but i can
tell you where things are going to end
up eventually whether it's in the
negotiation or in this round or the next
round
and sort of give them a grasp of what it
will eventually look like and you know
this is just based on experience just
the other day i had a founder call me
um he want you know he wanted to
restructure the whole company he had
many early on investors you know they
weren't contributing there's maybe down
round
there was a whole discussion and i
didn't have their cap table in front of
me but i told him listen from the sound
of it you know this is the cut the
investors are going to want you know and
there are no investors at the table yet
this is the ease of increase they'll
want the founders will get a juice up
you know
technically speaking in two rounds this
is no longer an issue so don't waste
your time and you know legal fees on you
know fixing something that's eventually
mute
um and i think that you know sort of
that whole you know understanding
you know what is ahead of us and and
what is you know the probable scenarios
that we're going to foresee you know if
you're looking at capitalization
um is you know it gives you some comfort
and and you know when you're able to say
you know it's going to end up this way
you know the last 50 times i've seen
this is this is where it ended up so you
know we can
you know
we can brainstorm on this we can insist
on that but it's eventually probably
going to go in this direction or another
and then it's either an on concern or
it's something that we can you know
address now if it's if it's something
that we're you know concerned with um
certain anti-dilution protection for
instance in such a case but
um i think i think having that so i have
a question exactly
so exactly in that regard and given the
holistic view that you're presenting
here i'm understanding the context and
the perspective of everything that's
happening you know how do we know as
founders what what should what we should
be really focusing on at any given deal
right so there are so many different
factors and so many different things
that that we may that we may be thinking
about as we as we approach these deals
and then we have to also know you know
what are we
what are we willing to fight about and
what can we compromise on is it simply
you know asking you and saying in bow
like what what should we do and what
should be concerned with or or are there
already patterns that you've seen that i
know already when i go raise my seed
round these are the these are the red
lines for me and these are the things
that i shouldn't really you know think
too much about
so yeah i think
i i think good legal counsel especially
in these very early stages is keeping
the client focused on what really
matters and you know
where are the red lines you know where
we shouldn't budge and where we
shouldn't um you know
it i i don't like to say it's a no-go
but you know there may be items that are
no go wish okay so i mean if you you
know desperately need the funding then
you know clearly you have less of a
leverage but that's you know that's just
um so it is about understanding from you
know from a trusted counsel what are the
things that you should be most concerned
with and what you know sort of
you know would
eventually wrap up in a certain way
um but it's also explaining that to i
usually represent companies and founders
so i don't usually represent funds i
sometimes represent funds but normally
for the most part i represent companies
but this is also you know going back to
council for the funds and and sort of
you know having that discussion openly
with them so whatever they're asking now
you know as a seed or preceded investor
will later come to haunt them because
you know no right you know later
investor will ask for anything less this
will be the starting point for any
future negotiations right
where
they're going to be in an interest
alignment with the founders probably
more than they are with the new
investors so for example and you know a
c round investor investing whatever 40
million 70 million
you know 100 million
um
dollars at a company valuation of you
know 400 or 600 it has much less in
common with the precinct investor who
invested two at five
then you know so at that point the seed
investor or precede and the founders are
much more aligned in interest than than
those investors may be amongst
themselves
so
i think the holistic you know business
oriented approach of you know let's all
be grown-ups and work together and you
know make this you know sustainable
um you know which i try and implement is
you know it goes around so you know
whatever we're doing now will be you
know duplicated over and over and over
you know and you know until an m a
and having that perspective in mind not
just for us as founders but also you
know when speaking with our investors
and making sure you know we all see that
is is is a part of my you know as a part
of my job and and it's a part of
protecting everybody's interests i mean
it always has to make sense and
and you know one of the ways you see it
um
is also with you know
back in the day you know it was um you
had the i would call it the wedding cake
you know it was the cheer do you know
the waterfall the double dip
and that's all being sort of flattened
out these days you never see that
anymore you don't see the double dip
everybody's doing the one x not
participating
i heard in the valley a while ago that
they've stopped even doing that people
are saying we'll just take ordinary
shares assuming the next guy also takes
ordinary shares you know because if he
gets preferred then i'll have what he's
having but if he's willing to take
ordinary then we'll just all take
ordinary the company's doing well that's
you know that's probably for everybody's
benefit um so
but but it is you know an understanding
of you know
it's a more mature understanding but you
know that's where we strive to be
right now what what is really the role
of of you
you know as a legal counsel and as a
partner from the legal side for
companies as as you go through the deals
are you really involved with also the
negotiation piece or is it mainly you
know executing and a negotiation that
was done between the founders and
investors in other words where do you
fit into this whole this whole prisma of
of the of the deal that's forming here
so usually we would have um
so usually the amount invested in the
pre-money valuation would be the two
factors that would be agreed between the
company and the um and the investors so
you know sometimes they may also agree
on the format i mean whether it's a safe
or you know as an interim financing
vehicle or full you know full-blown
equity investment
and then everything else is you know is
what i'm negotiating and it comes you
know and it's from the very you know you
know
big items in my view which is you know
the the ease up
reserve pool which can be significant on
percentages because if you're setting
aside 10 or 20 you know that's 10 of the
company you just gave away without
saying you did so you know an evaluation
or an amount raised
um
so that's one aspect but also um
you know protective provisions which are
veto rights you know very important
especially in early stage rounds um you
know other
preference rights that the you know the
preferreds may want you know whether
it's over allotment on you know
on next financing which i think is a
crucial point because you don't want to
block yourself from being able to get
more funding from other you know
parties that are not around the table
currently or from strategic investors um
it can be you know special provisions if
you know somebody's asking for a warrant
or double dip so really it's not just
execution but it really is you know
everything
normally other than the price or the you
know in the investment amount and i can
also tell you that sometimes i mean i've
had an experience where the company has
um
agreed to a certain safe you know
structure and amount with a certain
investor
and you know it was one of those um y
combinator post money saves that you
know they're very you know they look
like uh vanilla but they're very
actually complex because if you have
additional safes coming in afterwards
you're really just diluting the founders
um you know aggressively and people
don't it's a tweak people don't
necessarily understand um and i i sort
of ran the math with the founders and i
told them listen the way this is
structured you know like
the best case scenario is what we would
actually have if we just do you know
around right now at this valuation
because this could not get any better
for us this could just get worse and
then we shifted it and then we took it
from a safe format to just an equity
investment which you know would turn out
to be a very wide decision
um you know because they didn't meet
their you know next equity um
goal you know in the time frame that
they had thought and then they did need
an additional safe amount and you know
they would have really been hurt had
they gone you know that post money
safeway and not just you know a regular
equity round where everybody's in the
same boat and diluted you know by
whatever comes next so
yeah we
we do the entire negotiation and thought
process and and many times explaining i
mean
even founders if it's their first
investment round they'll definitely know
you know
you know what a cap table looks like
because you know most of them are pretty
messy but
but they won't understand what a double
dip is um you know what's liquidation
preference um what the veto rights mean
you know
the board composition is something we
would normally you know think about you
know together and you know what works
what makes sense what doesn't look too
bad you know you can't have a company
you know with seven board members you
know it's a company of three people it
just looks weird so
you know just
really every aspect of it
so what it sounds like is that there's
this huge puzzle there's so many
different possibilities and so many
different combinations of things that
you can do here and uh and
it sounds that one of the most amazing
you know parts of it is that you get to
build this whole foundation again and
again with different companies
now how much do you have to understand
really the product of what they're
building and really understanding
neither their technology or their
differentiation or their go to market
when it comes to these things in other
words how how aligned do you have to be
in order to be a good partner of theirs
throughout this negotiation journey and
deal structuring how much do you have to
be aligned on on the actual company
level and the vision of the company
so to be frank i think when you're when
you're doing just finance rounds
um you don't need more than a general
understanding
um you need it for mostly the reps and
warranties you need to know where the
exposures might be you know where the
company may be taking risks that you
would need to disclose
um
but
myself personally i don't only do
transactions so i also do license work
so for you know company
so you know i represent them in finance
rounds but then i can also represent
them you know in a sas agreement like a
huge enterprise license agreement so
then i actually need to understand their
product i don't need to understand it
you know to the core of it i don't need
to understand how the code works right i
need to know if it's on-prem if it's a
sas solution who's accessing you know
what i mean what are we giving them what
are the actual deliverables you know
sometimes it's a report sometimes it's a
recommendation sometimes it's you know a
dashboard so
you know yes
the more i understand and the better i
you know
i'm familiar with what exactly they're
doing you know the more i can be helpful
in you know putting together a contract
that is
you know
protective of you know their concerns
and understanding and you know this is
also interesting because recently we've
had a lot you know ai everybody's
talking about ai so that's um that's the
buzzword now
and i've just recently
changed definition for you know
permitted uses
um you know in many of the contracts
that i write to include you know the
you know just like a general license
that every client or customer of you
know
of my customers software
gives my customers
to enable the the software you know to
progress itself and to develop itself so
this is just like i don't want anybody
suing us you know two years down the
road hey your ai um algorithm
used my data pictures whatever to
improve the software now you're selling
that you know when you enhance and
improve software to somebody else um so
you know yeah these are things that you
you know you learn
the more i understand the more i learn
you know about what they're doing and
you know
then the better you know
the legal protection and you know sort
of creativity can be you know to an
extent amazing
inval really just sounds like a really
amazing a job and just a really fun
position to be in where you're you know
in one hand it sounds like you're you're
you're right of that sweet spot of
helping founders deal with things that
they may not have they're they're not
obviously not domain experts in this at
least most of them are not and you get
to fill in the shoes of a really
critical moment in their life cycle
where they are about to grow and they
need to do it in a really good way and
you're helping them build a foundation
to to continue having you know the right
growth with the right partners under the
right deal so that the company can
continue to succeed for many years and
not get stopped something way down the
line because of something they did five
years ago that they didn't really
realize and so it sounds like both it's
a really important job for the starters
but also it sounds like it's a really
fun one for you you know both the puzzle
pieces the math piece and then and it
sounds obviously you know with licensing
and the way that you're interacting with
the technology and understanding how sas
works and how these companies are built
you provide a lot of value there i
really want to thank you for taking the
time to join me i know how busy you are
and and i'll let you go back to helping
the many startups that you work with so
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy pleasure
thank you very much thank you stay
healthy
bye bye
[Music]
you